Ukrainian officials dismissing a claim
by the head of the Wagner
Private Army Group, who had said that
Russian forces
hold back mode in, quote, legal terms.
Yevgeny Prigozhin
made that claim in this video,
which he said showed him
raising a Russian flag
at the side of a council building,
a Ukraine
military
spokesman says the video
is incomprehensible.
David McKenzie
joining us with the very latest.
He's on the ground
in Kiev in Ukraine for you David.
Well, that's right.
That video,
which is, of course, taken at night
and not exactly
clear what we are seeing there.
But Prigozhin claimed
that they had in a legal sense,
taken back
that heavily contested city
in the eastern part of the front.
Now, Ukrainian officials
saying that's, quote, wishful thinking.
They say
while that is a very difficult situation,
they still control certain
sections of that city.
And importantly,
they say they are able
to get food, medicine and the wounded
out of that area, as well as ammunition.
So and they also point out,
I think, which is important, that over
many, many months
the Russians and the private
military contractors
have not been able to take back money.
That much is clear.
You know, the ongoing shelling
and rocket attacks
and missile attacks
in the eastern part of the country
and frankly, throughout this country
have had a devastating toll
on soldiers and civilians alike.
We got rare access inside a team of U.S.
and Canadian
surgeons working to
reconstruct Ukrainian faces.
I must warn some viewers
they could find some of
these images, disturbing
levels
and. Right.
The impact
of war is hard to look at my finger.
The difficulty that that I'm having
is that
I don't know what anything looks like
behind the skin here.
I can make an opening
that looks like there's an eye,
but they're never going
to look like normal eyelids.
And the surgical realities
are nothing like civilian life.
Okay.
How do you compare it to here in Ukraine?
Well, the level of complexity
for these cases is significantly
more elaborate
and significantly more complex.
We think we can get the mouth
working better.
Face a future mission.
Director Anthony Perseid
says the blast injuries
are often devastating.
One of the things that we can do
is improve
the appearance of the scar,
multi-level bone
and soft tissue injuries.
It really does not get any more complex
than this, even in a combat scenario.
They brought together
highly specialized plastic
surgeons, anesthesiologists
and nurses from the US and Canada
to reconstruct and repair.
All that bone is missing
what many cannot.
And if we can do that,
then that certainly is
a fulfilling opportunity.
So it's not just a physical change,
it's a psychological help you hope.
Absolutely. Absolutely.
And it's a psychological help
not just for the patient,
but also for their family.
Roman Polanski is one of their patients.
He's invited us to his home
What do I think of him?
I'm proud of my son,
says his mother, Lisa Thomas.
I'm proud of him.
I'm proud of the fact
that he didn't run away.
He didn't hide.
I should call some
early in the war.
His mechanized infantry
brigade faced the brunt
of Russia's invasion
and their oncoming tanks.
Are you surprised that you survived
I do not understand how I survived,
he says. Doesn't that make it worse?
I don't even understand
how I got through the shelling
because it was dark.
The night I was hanging out,
I was concussed.
My whole face was covered in blood
Shrapnel went right through me.
It shouldn't lose.
As he says, many in
his brigade were lost.
We were all like one family, he says.
You know, somewhere you feel your guilt.
But I didn't also die like they did.
Roman lived
And this will be his third surgery
with Dr. John Croteau.
What what bothers you the most now?
Our hope is that at some point
they leave happy
and then I don't see them again.
On my end,
I have to appreciate we're making steps
because we don't fix them
if we make them better.
So this is where we shine,
which is in the operating room.
All of the steps and activities
that we were doing
before getting here
is really to get us to this point.
Roman surgery
is one of the first of the day.
He says Dr.
Friedel and the team have already
put him back together and saved his life.
Dr.
Frodo is
working to remove a cheek implant
just a tiny bit higher honor.
Among the margins in this kind of surgery
are very small,
but the differences for the patients
can be huge.
A person's appearance
is a reflection of their inner spirit,
of their inner self to the world
and we must never forget that.
But everyone wants to have
a facial appearance
that others want to look at.
I would want to get to know him.
It's part of the human condition
I've been in touch with Dr.
Frodo, Becky, over the next few days
after that surgery of Ramon.
He says that Roman's doing well.
The swelling will eventually come down.
They're coming back in
just a matter of weeks.
As we say in that report,
there takes a long term commitment.
And part of the commitment
is the patients themselves deciding
whether they want to go on
with these multiple surgeries
that at times make marginal differences.
But in general,
they're making a huge difference
in their lives. Becky.
It is it is absolutely remarkable.
Their work is to be absolutely applauded.